عبد السلام تذكر انه منذ بضعه ايام كان
هناك حديث عن اعتقال احد المتعهدين في
مطار اسطنبول وهو المتعهد الذي بنى مجمعا
شهيرا في مدينه هاتاي نحن هنا عند هذا
المجمع الذي هو في مدينه هاتاي دعني انقل
الصوره ربما قليلا لنرى هذا المكان المجمع
السكني هو هناك وقد سقط هذا المجمع
كعلبه كبريتا اهتزت تحتها المنضده اثار
الدمار في المكان كبيره يفترض ان هذا
المجمع هو احد المجمعات الحديثه
والتي ربما
مقاومه قد تكون
لزلازل ولكن مع ذلك هي كحال كحالها كحال
غيرها ايضا تاثرت في الزلزال لكن كان
واضحا ان هذا المجمع لم يسقط كما تسقط
الاتربه او كما تسقط الا في المواقع
الاخرى هو تماما سقط الى الخلف لاحظ هناك
اليات العمل هي تقوم
بمحاوله ايضا تحطيم بعض الاماكن هناك تجمع
لاهالي هذا المجمع في مكان قريبا من هنا
يقولون انهم يريدون الوصول الى ذويهم
الذين كانوا موجودين اساسا في هذا المجمع
عندما حدث الزلزال وهم يقولون اما ان نصل
اليهم احياء او اعطونا جثثهم الابنيه
المجاوره ايضا هي تضررت بشكل كبير كما
تشاهد في الصوره الزلزال بلغ شده عاليه
الى درجه ان هذه الابنيه في معظمها تدمرت
هناك ربما بعض الاشخاص ايضا
قاموا بازاله بعض المصاحف التي وجدت في
المكان
ووضعها في
في على جانب الطريق لحمايتها كل ذلك ربما
هو ينقل بعض التفاصيل من حياه البشر التي
الذين كانوا هنا رايته قبل قليل بعض
الاشخاص الذين حاولوا الدخول الى هذه
المباني
الهايله للسقوط الهائله للسقوط وجلب بعض
الاغراض سالتهم كيف تخاطرون بالدخول الى
هناك قالوا انهم بحاجه الى بعض الاغراض
وانهم سالوا الشرطه
وان سمحت لهم باخذ بعض الاغراض قبل قليل
ايضا كان هناك شخص يبحث عن حيوانه الاليف
هي مئات بل الالوف القصص في اماكن كهذه
تحدث عندما يحدث زلزال كبير ينتج عنه
تدمير شاسع كهذا الزلزال